INCENTIVES FOR STATES TO PASS
RED FLAG LAWS.
>> LAUREN FOX WITH THE LATEST ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO TO
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT RED FLAG
LAWS, THAT MAKES IT EASIER FOR
TEACHERS AND FACULTY TO CARRY
GUNS IN SCHOOL.
THE HOURS OF TRAINING WENT FROM
700 TO 24, AND CRITICS ARE
WARNING OF DANGEROUS
CONSEQUENCES.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER SITUATION, ARE THESE
TEACHERS ARE GOING TO BE
PROFICIENT ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
BE ON TARGET AND NOT STRIKE
OTHER STUDENTS IN A CROWDED
CAFETERIA OR GYM OR AUDITORIUM
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE MASS CHAOS
WHEN THIS SHOOTING OCCURS.
>> OHIO BECAME THE 23rd STATE TO
ALLOW PERMITLESS CONCEALED
CARRY.
JOINING ME IS MELISSA CROPPER,
PRESIDENT OF THE OHIO FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS.
MELISSA, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH ME.
I KNOW THAT YOU AND YOUR GROUP
OPPOSE THIS NEW LAW.
I WANT TO START, THOUGH, WITH
THE GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR DEWINE
DEFENDING HIS SIGNATURE ON THIS
NEW LEGISLATION, LET'S WATCH.
>> WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE, DONE BY SIGNING IT, IS
GIVING SCHOOLS AN OPTION BASED
ON THEIR PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCES TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION THEY CAN MAKE WITH THE
BEST INFORMATION THEY HAVE.
THAT'S ALL ANY DECISION MAKER
CAN DO.
>> NOW, I UNDERSTAND YOU OPPOSE
IT.
TELL ME WHY.
>> WELL, THIS IS JUST
PREPOSTEROUS TO THINK THAT A
TEACHER WOULD BE ABLE TO STOP AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER IS THE WRONG
NOTION ANYWAY, AND THEN TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF HOURS OF
TRAINING FROM OVER 700 HOURS TO
24 HOURS IS REALLY JUST A
DISTRACTION FROM THE FACT THAT
OUR LEGISLATURE IS DOING
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO MAKE OUR
STUDENTS SAFER.
>> SO WHY DO YOU THINK, THEN,
THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT?
>> I THINK THE GOVERNOR, AGAIN,
IS TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM THE
FACT THAT WE HAD A MASS SHOOTING
IN DAYTON A FEW YEARS AGO.
THE PEOPLE OF OHIO DEMAND HE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT, AND HE HAS
DONE NOTHING ABOUT IT.
THIS IS THE ANSWER TO DO
SOMETHING IS TO ARM TEACHERS.
THIS NOT ONLY MAKES OUR SCHOOLS
MORE UNSAFE, IT DOES NOTHING TO
HELP PEOPLE IN THE GROCERY
STORES, WALKING ON THE STREETS.
>> AFTER THE SENATE PASSED IT
BEFORE THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT, I
SPOKE WITH THE SENATE COSPONSOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION, I WANT YOU
TO LISTEN TO PART OF HER DEFENSE
AND THEN LET'S TALK.
>> THERE ARE SOME AREAS OF OUR
CITY WHERE RESPONSE TIME CAN BE
VERY QUICK, AND SPEEDY IN AN
EMERGENCY WHEN MINUTES AND
SECONDS COUNT, BUT THERE ARE
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE THAT
ARE MORE RURAL OR SOME OF THE
AREAS ARE GOING TO BE MORE
DIFFICULT TO GET SOMEONE THERE.
>> SO WE'VE SEEN THE FAILED
RESPONSE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
UVALDE, IN PARKLAND AS WELL, AND
THOSE, YES, ARE THE OUTLIERS,
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE, WHAT
SHOULD BE THE PROTECTIONS FOR
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT ARE MAYBE TOO
LONG OF A DRIVE FROM THE CLOSEST
SHERIFF'S OFFICE?
>> THE PROTECTION IS TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM GETTING THE GUNS TO
START WITH.
LET'S MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE -- LET'S DO DEEPER
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
LET'S MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE GUNS
TO GET GUNS AND LET'S STOP
PUTTING AR-15s IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW WE REALLY PROTECT
PEOPLE, NOT BY PUTTING MORE GUNS
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
UVALDE SHOWED THAT A GOOD GUY
WITH A GUN CANNOT STOP A BAD GUY
WITH AN AR-15.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
REMEMBER.
>> SO I KNOW THAT CLEVELAND AND
COLUMBUS, I'VE READ, THEY SAY
THEY WILL NOT CHANGE THEIR
POLICY.
ARE YOU SEEING -- HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM ANY OF THE BIGGER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
WILL ALLOW THEIR TEACHERS, THEIR
ADMINISTRATORS TO CARRY?
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD OF THAT YET.
I THINK CINCINNATI IS ALSO
LOOKING AT NOT DOING THIS WITH
THEIR TEACHERS, SO I THINK OUR
LARGER SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE NOT
CONSIDERING THIS OPTION, AND
AGAIN, REMEMBER, I THINK ONE
THING, THE IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER ABOUT OHIO IS THAT THE
OPTION HAS ALREADY BEEN THERE TO
ARM TEACHERS IN SCHOOLS.
WHAT THIS LAW DID WAS REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF TRAINING FROM OVER 700
HOURS OF TRAINING TO ONLY 24
HOURS OF TRAINING.
MOST OF THAT TRAINING NOT EVEN
BEING DONE WITH A GUN.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, THE
POLICE UNION, THEY'RE AGAINST
IT, BUT NOW THAT IT'S LAW, AND
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALLOW
THEIR TEACHERS TO CARRY, THEY
HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE, THEY HAVE
TO ADJUST.
SOME PRINCIPLES IN THESE
DISTRICTS MAY DISAGREE WITH IT,
THEIR TEACHERS MAY WANT TO
CARRY.
THEIR ORGANIZATION OFFERS
RESOURCES FOR THE CLASSROOM,
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT, WHAT
WILL BE THE TREATMENT OF
POTENTIALLY TEACHERS WHO WANT TO
CARRY.
WILL THERE BE ANY RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
PROFICIENT EVEN IF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOESN'T.
HOW WILL YOU TRY TO EVEN WITH
THIS LAW NOW IN PLACE, MAKE SURE
THAT CLASSROOMS ARE AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE?
>> WE WILL BE WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS, OUR
LOCAL UNIONS TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS WITHIN THAT LOCAL
THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS.
WE WILL BE PUSHING FOR MORE
RESOURCES IN THE CLASSROOM AND
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO HIRE
SAFETY PERSONNEL IF NEEDED AND
NOT TO BE USING OUR TEACHERS, IN
CASES WHERE DISTRICTS CHOOSE TO
USE TEACHERS AS SECURITY
PERSONNEL, WE WILL CERTAINLY BE
PUSHING FOR A MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
TRAINING.
THIS LAW DOES NOT SAY THAT YOU
COULD ONLY HAVE 24 HOURS OF
TRAINING.
THAT'S A MINIMUM.
WE WILL STILL BE ENCOURAGING OUR
PEOPLE TO GET A FULL 700 HOURS
OF TRAINING, BUT AGAIN, THE MORE
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT WE WILL
BE PUSHING FOR MORE RESOURCES IN
OUR SCHOOL, SUCH AS SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH, YOU KNOW,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, ALL OF THOSE
OTHER RESOURCES THAT WE NEED I